hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we're gonna watch a video
will Robert the narrowing it and your
son of a [ __ ] show I don't know what
this is at Google
good good bagels ad awesome I'm a
commercial this is the right way to get
hyped for the irishman trailer or
whatever that comes out one of our top
reward tiers on patreon is whatever
video you requested was due and put up
on YouTube today comes from our great
friend David Gandy but well as far back
as I can remember I always wanted to
make known that that my New York
associates we've been thinking who's
this skinny kid muscling in on a bagel
business skinny that's all I'm still
that guy you got a nice family business
here Johnny boy very nice and it's given
me an idea picture this I take my family
business turbofolk
[Music]
it's made my crew and some local move
shut up and drive and what do you know
the perfect product falls straight and
all that
it's like a fake that's right go fill
them something nice boys go to work
[Music]
but you want to make it in the paper
business you've got to break some breaks
once we've taken care of a competition
ashes to ashes what's the process well
we gotta do
sit back and watch the Gogol
nice
baby boom casino don't forget about it I
was one of the best Robert DeNiro being
a parody version of himself I have ever
seen probably so committed better than
half the movies where he's a parody of
himself yeah it was really committed to
every bit of dialogue there weirdly this
does get me excited for the Irishman
because there are nods to good fellows
throughout just calling good bagels in
general be like the whole heist element
the red lighting when they're digging up
the dirt in reference to the body when
they're burying it in Goodfellas even
his outfit in the end all four it looks
like a scene oh I love it I love that
man not only that but it makes you real
hungry for a bagel yeah this is really
witty this was like very clever I like
all the puns you're like when you know
like that commercial can have a little
breathing room I mean this is two
minutes long so it can actually be kind
of a fun amusing scene instead of oh
here's Robert De Niro to remind you to
buy a bagel and you're done whoever this
commercial director is did a really good
job at mirroring the Scorsese kind of
framing as well as the types of tracking
and zoomin shots and the montage element
making fun of all their character names
of the freeze-frame
I would have believed this if directors
yes yeah yeah one just all the different
bread dough roll puns you know popping
up in all the different spots from crust
the crust do you know things that I
thought those were really charming have
you ever seen the video where De Niro
gets mad when he's filming a commercial
he's being directed no let's pull it up
let's watch that video I don't remember
what this is for maybe we'll hear it in
here things like our commercial or
something there's like 30 seconds when
we created Tribeca we wanted to capture
all the in our mind all the energy and
all the power of the movie see for
yourself
Tuesday on Fox
I'm sorry I got that's energetic you
don't know you know what you're talking
about
yes he's not selling cars that's what I
thought it was a man but of all the
celebrity rants I've seen that's
probably the most low-key I mean he gets
pretty mad at Trump these days he's
gonna punch him in the face and all
these things he talks how well he wants
to punch people in the face and I'd like
to punch him in the face
hey I mean that would make for a great
reaction video me for a great reaction
but and a great way to enjoy a bagel
navilet De Niro could only just commit
this much to some of the comedies he
does as much as he committed this
commercial De Niro needs to start only
doing two minute short yes maybe that's
like where his true purest commitment is
all right guys well did you like this
commercial if you liked this video hit
that like button a lot of people aren't
encouraging that these days for a reason
notification bells click them hit the
subscribe button leave a comment share
it on social media
go outside and shout to all your friends
watch the real rejects kill your family
what David Gandy thank you so much for
requesting this buddy you get the most
sincerest of the shoutouts you and I are
like pen pals these days via patreon
messages and I just love the hell out of
you man you keep on stretching you keep
getting loose I know you're doing
martial arts plus a lot of heavy intense
workouts you're and I think 50s 60s and
you're working out what sounds like 9
times a week when you tell me be careful
buddy you don't want to pull anything
but you're gonna be like the most jacked
older dude in a few months you know so
get ready
pull some speedo seasons upon us pull
some muscle Beach can you pull
that might be a different way to let off
some steam master you got a job